the movie's fake wait they didn't get
married Bro they didn't get married
Eddie Murphy's not a Nation of Islam
Julia Louis dreyf is not Jewish he might
be Jewish I didn't stop the capital yeah
I guess he didn't okay we had a podcast
that day yeah no we were busy my point
is there's these people that are getting
like so upset that I exposed that a
movie was for avatars not real I hate to
break it to you Avatar is not a real
movie what I'm confused about is
why people at home are like nothing
better kiss yeah
while to respect shorty and her
decisions if she doesn't want to don't
respect Jonah in his decision maybe she
feels the uncomfortable doing in front
of that many people there's hundreds of
people in the room because it's a
wedding scene where is this this
audience out of nowhere that's like for
me to believe the plot it better make
out yeah who the are you watch the
free movie on Netflix did you steal the
password from your ex-wife
but you're still allowed to do shots